until last year mark moore was home to
some 200,000 people and about a third of
them Arabs the city fell to the Islamic
state or dash as they're known here last
August but Kurdish forces backed by US
airstrikes soon retook it although
fighting continues in the surrounding
area people have started returning to
the city but so far those coming back at
all kurds and many residents like that
thank God the situation in much more
secure now but we absolutely don't want
any Arabs coming back I lost trust in
them and all araphi I don't expect that
they will come back they're all dash and
support dash there were our friends they
were close to us and they betrayed us by
joining dash while is vital but Lana
comes our should be new corner at a
refugee camp in nearby debugger Mama's
displaced Arab residents deny their
collaborators they say they're also
victims of the Islamic state this man
wanted to remain anonymous he's afraid
that the militants could retaliate
against members of his family who are
living in areas controlled by the
Islamic state hot de lo cambia Hector
look unbeatable normal that the
situation change dr. dash was now the
Kurds are fighting dash and spending a
lot of money on the wall so it dad says
our attitude towards Arabs has changed
Gamu it thrown my top and three original
or on TJ Halep leonel adoro show more
unfortunately some people think all Arab
support dash but but it isn't true that
every Arab is dash Lee Adam the Sierra
yeah double couldn't all be that dash
began by beheading Arabs first a dora
shelwyn Misbah house bowel Adam
officials here still hope macklemore's
Arab residents will return peaceful
coexistence between Arabs and Kurds
since 2003 is what has kept the area
safe and free from extremism says the
city's Kurdish mayor Ibrahim sha Allah
while we had that
good cooperation with Arabs people Kurds
and Arabs people in this area and there
they didn't direct to any terrorist
activities or terrorist organizations we
had a safe area we had a safe area and
both cottage and people have lived in
peace in this area the regional
government is showing its commitment to
macklemore's displaced Arabs by funding
the camp where they're now living the
families are grateful for the support
they're also counting on Kurdish
authorities to keep them safe make their
stolen guilty we're not afraid of being
attacked because the government is
responsible for everything and will
prevent anyone from harming but it's
true we know if people take things into
their own hands maybe they would come
and murder us civil the mayor has
appealed to the town's Kurds to resolve
any problems through legal means and not
carry out revenge attacks but with the
Islamic state still controlling some
areas around the town the situation is
tense and unpredictable no one knows
when the militants will be driven out
but one thing is certain it's a
challenging way ahead both for anti
Islamic state forces and for Kurdish
Arab relations